if you were to hack into my iPhone and
see my news feed you'd find out that
ninety percent of what I consume it's
either comedy or philosophy and it's
because they share one common trait
they're both true one of the things
that's interesting about philosophers is
that they State truths in platitudes
that are Eternal which is why I like
them because they become pillars of how
we can see the world but what's
interesting is that comedians also say
things that are true but they're true
contextually they say common things that
are obvious but people don't take the
time to observe I love the juxtaposition
of both those things which is one is
contextual truths the others are Eternal
truths those are the things that I drive
the most Joy from and I think it's
because they continue to shift my
perspective on my own reality